[Music]
october 1988. scp foundation agent cyril
novak and diana fisher have been
dispatched to austria's capital city
vienna to investigate a series of
mysterious unexplained disappearances
the foundation was unsure if these
events were connected or even anomalous
in nature but they had reason to believe
that something was lurking beneath the
dark streets of vienna a foundation
operative embedded in local law
enforcement informed the organization
that the authorities were panicking with
an emphasis on withholding information
about these disappearances from the
public and the media novak and fisher
conducted a survey of the city observing
the streets at night and keeping a
watchful eye on those who they deemed at
risk it was the undesirables of society
that were disappearing in droves
unsupervised children vagrants the
homeless all those that were indisposed
vulnerable and otherwise at risk of
being forgotten by society were
potential victims according to several
sources these disappearances were taking
place near access points to the city's
subterranean infrastructure sewer holes
access tunnels storm drains anywhere
that led to the underground was a
potential risk site after a few days of
standard exploration and information
gathering around vienna novak and fisher
moved on to interviews with law
enforcement and public officials using a
variety of cover stories they managed to
pry out a deadly secret from the mouth
of the police chief human remains had
been recovered near the disappearance
sites the authorities opted to keep them
a secret from the public so as not to
cause any panic of a crazed serial
killer on the loose or inspire fears of
something even worse lurking in the
city's underground the agent seized the
three cadavers and alerted the
foundation that their mission had been
progressing as expected the bodies were
transported to humanoid containment site
282 in guras austria where they were
immediately examined by dr felix gattner
who performed an autopsy on the three
corpses if the foundation was unsure
about anomalous involvement before they
were certain of it now the bodies were
in shambles mutilated beyond belief and
altered into an almost unrecognizable
state the mere stench of them caused
personnel working with them to rush to
the bathroom and even those that could
typically keep their lunch down had a
difficult time examining them cadaver a
the cause of death was determined to be
from exsanguination or the extreme loss
of blood cadaver bee was missing some
important fleshy components inside and
out some of which had been removed
entirely the cause of death was presumed
to be traumatic cardiac arrest the third
corpse could ever see was barely a body
instead it was a collection of bones and
fluids the cause of death because of the
opaque conditions the cadaver was found
in was unknown these grisly deaths were
only the start of the foundation's
containment of this anomaly and are far
from the worst this file has to offer
this is scp explained and today we're
going to be looking at scp-3288
a collection of entities otherwise known
as the aristocrats dr gartner's analysis
of the cadavers came to a single
conclusion a human could not do this in
fact he compared the deceased's injuries
and conditions with the bodies of
victims of hyena attacks all sustained
injuries weren't the result of a blunt
object sharpened blade or a firearm but
instead resulted from a combination of
teeth claws and raw physical strength
the bodies had abnormally large bite
marks approximately six times the size
of adult human teeth yet closer analysis
revealed that the indentations did in
fact coincide with human teeth whatever
did this possessed more than 60 teeth
unevenly distributed over six distinct
rows and required jaws much larger than
those of ordinary humans there were
unique patterns among these markings
suggesting that it wasn't a single
entity that ravaged these corpses but
multiple there was no doubt about it
these deaths were anomalous in nature
the foundation issued a designation for
the entities responsible
scp-3288 and deployed mobile task force
sigma-6 hellsingers a special unit
trained to capture deadly anomalies in
the field to bring
scp-3288 into foundation custody the
operatives were tasked with patrolling
the lepeled stock district the area
where most of the disappearances had
occurred secrecy as usual was a top
priority and members of the task force
took extra care to conduct their
operations away from the public eye as
the purpose of this mission was to
contain the entities for further study
the operatives were also ordered to
refrain from lethal force and to target
scp-3288 with tracking darts to prevent
them from escaping the task force
divided up their assignments 12
operatives would patrol the district and
search for any suspicious activity while
10 others would remain watch in
positions with unrestricted views of
sewer holes and other underground access
areas for the first few hours things
were quiet but then two operatives
stationed near the danube canal made a
report to the rest of the team someone
near the canal was screaming not loudly
but in a muffled faint way the
operatives took initiatives and ran off
to investigate the matter themselves
requesting backup at the same time
reinforcements arrived less than three
minutes later but their teammates could
not be found moments later their bodies
were discovered by another operative
mangled beyond belief both operatives
were killed and alongside them was a
half-consumed corpse of a local civilian
as well one operative's body was
recovered from the canal while the other
was found after following a trail of
blood and fluids into an alleyway but
despite the loss of life the mission was
still deemed a success before being
mauled by the
scp-3288 instance the task force
operative managed to shoot the entity
with a tracking bullet a piece of
technology utilizing satellite location
which allowed the rest of the team to
follow the entity into the sewers the
tracking was working perfectly and the
entity was shown to be fleeing into
vienna's sewer system until the signal
faded somewhere near the hofburg a
palace constructed centuries ago that
was once host to the habsburg dynasty
and presently serves as the seat of
power for the president of austria the
team was confused as the fading nature
of the signal suggested that the
tracking bullet had been brought into a
location far deeper than the viennese
sewers were believed to accommodate the
mission moved onward into the depths of
the sewers in pursuit of scp-3288
the following day the task force had
assembled a strategy for mapping and
exploring the viennese sewer system
constructed in the mid-19th century
these sewers were part of a larger
network of subterranean tunnels that
include catacombs abandoned wine cellars
and underground rivers without proper
planning and clear communication death
could be a very real possibility and not
even one caused by scp-3288
the task force was divided into four
teams of five three to investigate the
sewers and one to remain on standby by
triangulating the location of the
tracked instance the foundation was able
to pinpoint the general area they would
need to explore by blocking off certain
exits and surface access points they
hope to minimize the possibility of the
entity's escape or exposure to the
public while the primary objective
remain containing an scp-3288 instance
for scientific research lethal force was
authorized to be used in case of
emergencies the foundation valued the
lives of its trained soldiers and put
them above nearly anything still the
authorization of lethal force spelled
impending doom for many experienced
veterans of the task force they knew all
too well about what kind of entity they
were up against when the foundation
opted to skip the containment step and
prioritize getting out alive a team of
operatives reached their destination
safely but didn't discover anything of
significance during their trek through
the sewers of vienna at least not at
first after several hours of
investigation they encountered human
skeletal remains while making their way
through waist-deep sewage one member of
the task force pointed out a loose brick
in the wall and then another did some
minutes later inspection of the area
found a number of loose-fitting bricks
that were able to be removed with ease
as if they were put there to hide
something when the entryway was fully
unearthed it revealed a previously
unseen chamber whose walls were engraved
with the house of habsburg's coat of
arms operatives inside of the chamber
immediately knew what they were looking
at a family crypt of royal bloodline
never uncovered before the forgotten
atmosphere made them feel like they were
discovering a secret that they were
never supposed to know 24 sarcophagi
were found within the chamber and
historical records of the sewers and
surrounding area mention nothing about a
crypt beneath the palace multiple
statues were recovered from the chamber
as well depicting veiled women with
hushed expressions holding a finger to
their lips almost as if to say that this
place was a royal secret and trespassing
had grave consequences get it grave
consequences no
okay moving on
thought i would be funny today the tombs
themselves were intricate decorated with
ornate jewelry and various expensive
embellishments but did not include
placards markings or any indication as
to who was entombed within when the
operatives opened the sarcophagi they
were disgusted
the skeletal remains of over 300 bodies
all displaying severe and likely fatal
birth deformities
the team was at a loss what was the
meaning of this room the entrance had
been destroyed some time ago with stairs
shattered and buried among the stone
near the other side of the row of tombs
was a vault door coated in bronze and
bearing the coat of arms of the
habsburgs a seal written in latin was
engraved beneath the coat translated at
red for purity of blood the task force
tried to pry the door open but it
wouldn't budge opening it would require
special equipment and after what they
had witnessed inside the sarcophagus
some members of the team were even
hesitant to continue trying the team was
ordered by the supervising team to hold
their location and await the arrival of
another team that would open the door
foundation agents on the surface
organized a temporary evacuation of the
hofburg building the team waited for
backup throughout the night they made
attempts to open the vault but to no
avail once the surface had been properly
evacuated and an infiltration team
arrived inside the chamber to assist
with the vault door the gate was able to
be opened using oxygen fuel cutting
torches over a period of two hours once
opened the team was met with an ominous
descending staircase leading to an
unknown dark location underneath the
palace an eight-man squad heavily armed
and equipped with recording devices
ventured down the staircase radio
transmissions from the squad grew
increasingly faint over time when they
reached the estimated 65 meter mark
underground their communications arrays
were barely audible at the bottom of the
stairwell was an ornate foyer instead of
decaying gray stone walls and oceans of
sewage there were marble floors with
felted carpets and white painted walls
and ceilings this chamber was found to
be architecturally identical to a
certain wing of the hofburg palace
furthermore the chamber was clearly
built in the 18th century as many
aesthetic choices popular during that
era were clearly present much like the
crypt there were sculptures and statues
but this time there were also columns
paintings and tattered tapestries some
of the operatives admiring the beauty of
the room overlooked that on every piece
of art any and all depictions of the
human form were defaced and altered the
air was rancid with operatives
describing the odor as similar to rotten
meat and stale sweat the floor and walls
were discolored with what appeared to be
dried old blood regardless they moved
forward in between the space equivalent
of the hofburg imperial library was a
laboratory not found in the palace above
an operative collected numerous
documents relating to alchemy biology
and the occult as well as a journal of
transactions contracts and private
writings these documents were delivered
to above personnel and were later
translated by foundation personnel all
along the chamber were human remains
decomposing and strewn around the palace
suddenly a bell tolled and the music of
a pipe organ began playing discordantly
for over three minutes operatives hid
themselves and deactivated their
flashlights some hiding behind the
curtains of a large opera hall and
others behind large instruments they
heard footsteps in the distance minutes
later a group of figures emerged into
the palace hall these entities the
foundation had classified as
scp-3288 were now fully visible their
outfits were typical of the 18th century
containing deep shades of red that
contrasted with their stark white skin
porcelain masquerade masks and powdered
wigs their bodies were monstrous with
arms dragging across the floor uneven
faces long fingers some possessing more
than ten of and hunched backs a pair of
smaller instances entered behind the
horde of others and one blew a rusted
trumpet while the other held a banner
depicting the hapsburg crest the
trumpeteer began speaking but its words
were unintelligible and raw guttural
moans they ran out of the way their
stunted legs causing them to trip across
the floor there were now over several
hundred
scp-3288 instances inside the ballroom
multiple operatives activated silent
distress calls requesting backup to deal
with the massive entities they would
have to contain these instances bowed
their heads and another mass of
footsteps were heard as a group of
scp-3288 instances carried a morbidly
obese instance atop a throne it wore a
cape a red veil in place of a mask and a
crown too small for its head it was
evident that this was their leader a
large cauldron was placed before the
king a small instance climbed atop the
king's shoulder and lifted the entity's
veil to speak to it the cauldron was
uncovered and the king lurched forward
grabbing the tub and pouring its
contents down its massive mouth some of
the king's disgusting meals spilled from
its mouth revealing a small human child
with severe deformities the
scp-3288 instances warred in applause
and began to feast all while the
cacophony of noise brought on by the
various instruments inside the ballroom
raged on an operative hiding behind a
harpsichord was discovered by an
scp-3288 instance and quickly consumed
by it in the feeding frenzy the entities
were engaged in still barely alive
before being entirely digested by the
entity the consumed task force operative
triggered an explosive device from
within the entity's stomach with a look
of immediate discomfort the entity
suddenly exploded taking out several
other nearby 3288 instances with the
blast the entities were distraught and
while they were distracted the task
force leapt into action and rendered the
remaining
scp-3288 instances not killed by the
explosion unconscious using devices
loaded with a gas as foundation
reinforcements arrived the surviving
scp-3288 entities were contained and
moved to site 282 including the massive
king whose body was transported using a
specialized crane after the removal of
all remaining entities the pals was
filled with cement and re-buried with
the foundation making sure that no one
would ever discover it again after the
king was contained foundation personnel
were shocked to discover that the entity
could speak in an interview with the
hulking monstrosity it revealed that its
name was maximilian the great a
patriarch of the house habsburg the
entity's eyesight was severely damaged
from centuries of living underground and
the foundation was able to get the king
to comply by shining powerful lights in
its eyes the entity was delusional
believing itself still to be inside the
palace and referring to the doctor as
nothing more than mere meat which it
wanted to consume when the doctor was
able to convince the king that he too
was noble blood which the king believed
due to his unstable mental state the
entity uttered a chilling statement we
are of this same noble blood but some
are more noble than others our bloodline
is pure
untainted by outsiders we do not eat
human we eat peasants we eat
undesirables
we devour life undeserving of life that
is the nature of nobility what else
would be the point dna testing revealed
that the king was in fact descended from
the house of habsburgs as all
scp-3288 instances were
but what are the journal entries
discovered inside the palace after
translation the foundation found that
they contained the writings of leopold
the first a holy roman emperor and
member of the habsburg house in the
early 1700s his writings detailed his
desire to claim power over the royal
family as well as his fears of an
increased number of inbred deformed
members of the habsburg house leopold
details meeting a woman of unknown
origin who promised him that his family
name could live forever she taught him
arcane knowledge involving
experimentations of the flesh small
animals and eventually humans were
subject to leopold's disgusting unholy
experiments even his mystical teacher
became disgusted with what her tutelage
had wrought as payment she demanded that
leopold cease his reign deliver his land
and wealth to common people and destroy
his various deeds and titles leopold
refused and had the woman burned at the
stake for witchcraft eventually
leopold's experiments to make his
bloodline perpetual resulted in the
creation of scp-3288
years of inclusive family ties mutated
over one another generation after
generation until a horde of scp-3288
living underneath the palace and
feasting on a diet of human meat were
created for years the surface habsburgs
catered to scp-3288's depraved and
disgusting needs providing them with a
slew of humans to feast on and a lavish
lifestyle akin to the one lived by the
nobility above one other document
revealed to the foundation that there
were multiple hives of scp-3288
existing throughout europe most were
discovered and neutralized but the
original writing was heavily damaged by
mold meaning that there were some
locations the foundation was unable to
uncover colonies of
scp-3288 instances buried underground
snatching humans without any care
mutating their own deformities and
living horribly unable to be stopped a
captured
scp-3288 instance in germany revealed
that there was another entity similar to
the king in authority by the name of the
empress it had this to say to the
foundation upon being contained the meek
will be get this strong
the tuned will beget the chosen don't
you see
see greedy will devour the charitable
and the merciless will ravage the
peaceful the evil makes the world as
perfect as us
we will all be aristocrats in the end
and our dynasty
will never die
now go watch
scp-1678 on london and
scp-5545 mysterious tunnels in
antarctica abnormality for more
anomalous subterranean locations
[Music]